hey David I want to know how could we
actually have prevented the recent
shootings and I assume in the recent
shootings the the emailer is referring
to the synagogue shooting and the
shooting at the bar I mean really I
guess Pat any of the recent shootings
are fair game for the purposes of this
discussion what yeah I'm not sure if I'm
missing any important ones that they may
mean I think the two major of shootings
that they're referring to are the Sunnah
synagogue shooting and the one at
Thousand Oaks California so first of all
it's important to clarify that after an
event has happened discussions of how
that one particular event could have
been prevented are not particularly
useful especially since the truth is you
can't really prevent any one event
beyond doubt right if you have a
particular instance where you have an
individual determined to carry out
violence there are limits to what the
security apparatus the law enforcement
apparatus can actually do I think the
more important question here is what can
be done to reduce the prevalence of
these events and mitigate the
seriousness with which the events are
carried out the level of death and
violence that takes place and so a lot
of this is societal right so like here's
an example of something that wouldn't
work Donald Trump after I think it was
the synagogue shooting although it may
have been after after a different one
now it's there's been so many it's hard
to remember Donald Trump had the idea
that if you stiffen up the death penalty
if you expand the speed and and use of
the death penalty that you will deter
people from committing these acts in the
first place there's no evidence of that
there's no evidence that when you have
the death penalty as as the strictest
possible punishment versus life in
prison that people are committing fewer
acts particularly when a lot of these
individuals are taking their own lives
or or there they are killed by law
enforcement deliberately or because of
that's how it works out that doesn't
make any sense to me now
okay where I would look is number one
how do we prevent broader radicalization
of people how do we deal with the fact
that society has disaffected people who
end up looking at weapons as a way to go
out and solve their problems or react to
the problems that they are having an
individual event is much harder to
prevent what we can say is that in a lot
of these cases if the individual didn't
have access to the firearms that they
had it would have been far more
difficult for them to do what they did
now let's explore the synagogue shooting
could a very determined individual who
imagine if in April when mental health
professionals evaluated him they had
determined this guy is a danger to
himself and others he is no longer
allowed to have guns let's assumed if he
already owned the gun the gun was taken
away or he wasn't able to purchase a gun
if that synagogue shooter was determined
to on October 27th I believe the date
was go and kill people at this
particular synagogue in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania could they have done it
yeah they could have they could have
shown up with a knife and they could
have still potentially killed people
probably fewer people they could have
staked out the synagogue with a vehicle
and potentially run some people over but
it would have been more difficult and I
think that there Pat is where a lot of
these discussions go off the rails where
people want to say the guns are the only
issue or the guns don't matter well
listen it's gonna be tough to stop a
truly determined individual at all but
the hardest targets but the access to
the weapons does increase the ease with
which they can kill as many people as
they do certainly requires a nuanced
approach whenever you talk to a
right-wing or after a mass shooting at
say a school or a church or a mall they
always just say well if only the
teachers had guns if only the
parishioners had guns
if only the customers had guns then
maybe they could have stopped it we'll
take a look at the Thousand Oaks
California shooting it took place at
are just about everywhere in the US you
can't be intoxicated while carrying a
firearm and even if you're not
intoxicated most places you can't show
up to a bar with a firearm because it's
just against the law are you saying that
you want people who have been consuming
alcohol to all be strapped what if
there's a bar fight I mean these things
could end up devolving and the situation
that you have if there's a shooting
could end up escalating to a scale
that's much much worse than what it
otherwise would have been and I don't
think that that talking point stands up
especially in the California case and I
think it's really important that that
thinking doesn't get you to the gun laws
are irrelevant because people would
ignore them anyway systemically if there
are fewer guns around and it is more
difficult to get them you are going to
prevent many shootings and many
shootings will be less serious the other
thing I want to mention is we probably
need more federal resources the a lot of
these guys we find out had been have
been posting stuff online about killing
Jews or attacking this or that and we
just don't have the federal resources
the FBI can't keep up with every single
one of these I understand that in many
of them there's nothing necessarily
actionable to seize weapons or to put
them under constant surveillance it's
just not practical but more federal
resources for this particularly when we
see the rash of hate crimes would be
important the the important thing to
remember is a lot of in a sense the
shootings are side effects they are
deadly side effects they are destructive
life-altering side effects but they are
side effects of other problems and that
includes mental health issues ready
availability of weapons a cultural issue
we're in more people in the US than in
many other countries see weapons as a
tool that you can use to solve the
problems you're experiencing in the
world and that is something that also
needs to be dealt with